stuff clay said there are two questions
first clay said that he ranks this as
your number one finals performance
do you kind of agree with that and then
two draymond said he could kind of tell
by your demeanor the past couple days
that you were going to bring some extra
fire tonight did you feel something like
that brewing over the last couple days
since the loss
yeah just again it's kind of how we
wanted to start the game
we rely on draymond bringing that energy
and fire you know throughout the course
of the season and
year after year
i felt like
we just had to let everybody know that
we were here tonight and
you know whether that's their crowd
their team our team whoever wants to see
that energy and that that fire
we feed off of that
human and um
yeah i think it helped us kind of just
get settled into
the game because obviously our
experience
you can want it so bad you kind of get
in your own way a little bit and
everybody feels a little bit of pressure
and it can go the opposite way i wanted
to try to
leverage that there you know in a
positive direction for us to start the
game
i don't rate my performances though
let's just win the game
marcus thompson athletic steph that was
clearly a golden performance about you i
was
wondering and he's back
i was wondering uh
have you ever gotten into like
the crowd like that early in the game
you yelled at them and you know you were
flexing
you've done that before but like
normally later
what made you do it early and how
difficult was it to sit those first
couple of minutes in your golden
performance
first or the fourth quarter
i want to take that as a good sign
of how i feel physically like with my
foot and just
the low intensity of the game that i
wanted to be out there to start the
fourth
um
just because i felt good had a rhythm
and didn't feel tired at all
so i want to maintain that over the
course the rest of the series but
kind of the same answer as before just
we needed something
to settle into the game to start you
know
the game better
and
find some momentum
and just change the tone of you know how
physical they were in game three
and how we needed to respond game four
it wasn't a perfect first quarter but we
gave ourselves enough life
and that fire was uh me just trying to
show that we're here tonight and we
understand what the task at hand is and
thankfully we found a way to get it done